if you asked a random person on the
street to choose between the s p 500
and a professionally managed hedge fund
chances are most of them would choose
the hedge fund
and this makes sense i mean why would
you invest into the broad market
when you can have hundreds of financial
professionals actively manage your money
on a day-to-day basis though the
opportunity sounds
awfully attractive the average person
doesn't have access to a hedge fund
most hedge funds not only require that
you're a millionaire
but also that you invest 1 million
dollars into the hedge fund
itself these lofty requirements have
given hedge funds an image of being a
fancy investment tool for the filthy
rich
but when we peel back the layers we'll
see that hedge funds
aren't actually that fancy in fact an
investment into the s p 500
in 2010 would have produced nearly
triple the returns
of hedge funds so here's the truth about
hedge fund support returns
and why the rich levitate towards hedge
funds nonetheless
before we get into the various reasons
hedge funds underperform the market
let's first take a look at the proof the
following table showcases the average
returns produced by hedge funds
and the s p 500 every year since 2011.
as you can see the hedge funds
underperformed the s p 500
every single year on green ears they
made
less money and on red ears they lost
more money
if we do a bit of math we'll see if the
average annual return for hedge funds is
4.956 percent
while the average annual return for the
s p 500
is 14.4 percent so the s
p 500 crushed hedge funds over the past
10 years
warren buffett even predicted this
outcome way back in 2008
in 2008 warren buffett bet 1 million
dollars at the s p 500
would outperform hedge funds over the
next 10 years
by 2015 hedge funds were losing so badly
to the s p 500
that buffett's opponent ted sides
actually conceded two and a half years
early
so there is no question that hedge funds
have underperformed the market
but in reality this is not that fair of
a comparison
because there's so many more factors
that go into running a hedge fund such
as
hedging as the name suggests hedge funds
hedge their bets
meaning that they always play the market
to both sides they could be 99
confident that apple stock will be
higher than it is today 10 years from
now but
despite that they'll have to allocate a
portion of their portfolio to betting
against
apple now they don't have to straight up
short apple stock or
buy puts on apple but what they do have
to do
is somehow offset the risk they take on
by purchasing apple stock
and to do this they use something called
beta beta is a measure of a stock's
perceived volatility in comparison to
the overall market
the s p 500 is the baseline so stocks
that perform identically to the s p 500
have a beta value
of 1. stocks that outperform the market
like apple
and tesla have a beta value greater than
1. meanwhile
stocks that underperform the market but
are still positive have a beta value
between 0
and 1 and finally stocks or positions
that are negative when the market goes
up and vice versa
have a negative beta value some hedge
funds aim to maintain an overall beta
value
of zero which means that the fund is
neutral to the market
there are also hedge funds that strive
for negative beta values or even beta
values
above one but in most cases the goal is
to maintain a low beta value but not
quite zero
considering this most hedge funds are
consistently burning large amounts of
money maintaining low beta values
which prevents them from benefiting from
large moves in either direction
aside from hedging hedge funds burn a
lot of money on fees
when it comes to passive funds the fund
managers don't really have to do much
every quarter a couple of companies will
be kicked out of the s p 500
and a couple will be added so index fund
managers will have to go ahead
and buy and sell some positions every
quarter but that's pretty much it
as a result passive funds have extremely
small expense ratios
the vanguard s p 500 fund for instance
has an expense ratio of only 0.03
percent
this means that for every 100 to invest
into the fund
only 3 cents goes to the fund managers
on an annual basis
with hedge funds on the other hand
financial analysts and portfolio
managers dedicate their entire lives to
managing the fund
on average individuals working at hedge
funds and investment banks work 80 to
100 hours
every single week and given their
massive commitment
they expect to be well compensated the
standard fee structure at hedge funds
follow the 2
and 20 rule this rule suggests that
hedge funds will earn a management fee
of 2
per year and 20 of all generated profits
if we have a hedge fund that produces an
annual return of ten percent
the hedge fund would take four percent
off the top meaning that the actual
investor would only earn six percent
to make things worse for investors the
better the track history of a hedge fund
the higher their fees will be on the
flip side these high fees
are extremely lucrative for hedge fund
managers in 2020 for instance
the top paid hedge fund manager was
chase coleman and he earned a whopping
3 billion dollars i think you can see
how such a compensation would make a
massive dent
in investors returns and that brings us
into the next factor holding back hedge
funds which is
diversification the s p 500 is known as
one of the most diverse investments
available on the stock market as it
combines the gains and losses
of the top 500 publicly traded companies
but
at the end of the day the s p 500 only
deals with one asset class which is
stocks hedge funds on the other hand are
able to invest into anything
and everything they invest into real
estate
land derivatives bonds private companies
foreign currencies and
much more while some of these
investments such as derivatives
and private companies could provide
greater returns in the s p 500
most of these alternative investments
come nowhere close to the returns of the
stock market
take 10-year treasury bonds for instance
currently a 10-year treasury bond will
only pay you 1.3 percent per year
similarly real estate only appreciates
three to five percent per year
so when you have 10 in bonds 10 in real
estate
10 in cash and so on and so forth it's
extremely difficult to beat an index
that's 100 stocks
and that's why it's not really fair to
compare the overall returns of hedge
funds
with the s p 500 if you wanted a true
apples to apples comparison between the
two
you would need to look at only the stock
holdings of hedge funds and then
disregard the money spent on hedging the
portfolio
this is a much more accurate
representation of the returns hedge
funds would provide if they tried to
maximize returns
and we don't have to guess as there's
plenty of hedge funds that specifically
focus
on maximizing returns as you would guess
with all of their expertise and
insider knowledge they crush the markets
chuck acker for instance
boasts an annualized return of 46.4
percent over the past three years
philip lafont achieved an annualized
return of 49.9
over the past three years basically
everyone on this list boasts returns of
40 50 year after year after year
but by far the best hedge fund in
history is renaissance technology's
medallion fund
since 1988 the medallion fund has
achieved an annual average return
of 66 percent given their unbeatable
returns
they charge eye-popping fees of 27 and
after fees investors only get 39
but that's still way higher than the s p
if there are hundreds of hedge funds
that destroy the s p 500
why don't billionaires and institutions
spend their money across these high
flying hedge funds
well the answer is simple and it comes
down to the fundamental purpose
of hedge funds by nature hedge funds are
not designed to provide massive returns
and the wealthy do not invest into hedge
funds expecting high returns
rather their primary goal of hedge funds
is capital preservation
and this is what attracts billionaires
towards them here's the thing
billionaires already have plenty of
risky investments as the only way to
become a billionaire
is to make outsized bets on an industry
or company
90 to 95 of the wealth of most
billionaires is concentrated into one
maybe two companies and given that
they're a billionaire
their investment has clearly crushed the
market over the past several years
take amazon for instance if you invested
500 into amazon when they went to public
you would have 324 shares of amazon
today or about
1.184 million dollars that translates to
an annual rate of return of 38.23
considering this the last thing jeff
bezos would want to do
is go ahead and put the five percent of
amazon shares that he does liquidate
into a return oriented investment if
anything
he wants to reduce his exposure to the
market and hedge funds are often the
perfect way to accomplish this
you see though hedge funds get
obliterated by the market during bull
markets
the same cannot be said about bear
markets the truth is
the general market not only runs up
exponentially but it also falls
exponentially after the dot-com bubble
the nasdaq crashed 78
from its peak and individual tech
companies like amazon crashed
even further so if you were a tech
company owner in 2002
how are you going to live when all of
your money is tied up into amazon or
google you definitely don't want to sell
your shares at the bottom of the market
after the stock just crashed 95 percent
in such a scenario
it would be really nice to have an
investment that more or less held its
value
and this is where hedge funds come into
play hedge funds don't rise as much as
the market during bull markets
but they also don't fall as much as the
market during bear markets
this graph comparing hedge fund and the
s p 500 performance since 1995
perfectly outlines this key difference
as you can see
between 1995 and 2000 during the dot-com
bubble
the s p 500 doubled the returns of hedge
funds
but during the dot-com crash the hedge
funds basically went sideways
while the market got crushed and by 2002
hedge funds took the lead in the 2008
financial crisis
hedge funds did take a hit but the drop
is only about half as much as a drop
experienced by the markets and the
market didn't overtake hedge funds until
or 11 years after they lost the lead the
s p 500
has dominated since then but it's likely
that during the next bear market
will see hedge funds shine once again
this doesn't mean that index funds are
better than hedge funds
or the hedge funds are better than index
funds the reality
is that they're completely different
tools that serve completely different
purposes
index funds are perfect for capitalizing
on strong bull markets
while hedge funds are perfect for
generating extremely consistent returns
for decades at the end of the day hedge
funds
are quite complex and intricate but not
in the way you think
they're not some secret tool that the
rich use to make billions
in fact they're more of a wealth
preservation tool and
unless you have tens of millions in the
market you really have no need to be
hedging
with hedge funds did you guys realize
that hedge funds aren't actually as
fancy as they sound
comment that down below also drop a like
if you think index funds are the way to
go
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one